you just started identifying as female
two weeks ago
i'm not here to talk about my transition
i'm here to kick some
ass it's still funny but now it's not
satire now it's reality
this weight lifter who goes by the name
laurel hubbard i don't know his real
name but he's now going by the name
laurel
he will become the first
transgender athlete to compete at the
olympics
after being selected by new zealand for
the women's event at the tokyo games
this is a decision about the fairness
and the inclusion
this fella is of
a big burly dude okay and he's going to
compete
against very fit women but he's going to
be bigger and burlier than they are
because he's a man
and men are bigger and stronger than
women and i suspect
none of those things that i've just said
are permitted any longer i may be able
to stay on social media but i certainly
wouldn't be allowed to say such a thing
at a
cocktail party or in a corporate hr room
or
in the halls of government or in a
public school we're not really allowed
to say these plain facts anymore
but it is insane that a big burly dude
is going to engage in a weightlifting
competition next to women
and he's going to do very very well and
we're all supposed to pretend that this
is a wonderful
shocking historic thing south park
mocked this idea just two years ago this
was a punchline on south park
just two years ago joining me now is the
current champion of the strong woman
competition
strong woman miss woman do you feel
ready
oh yeah i'm ready david there are just
so many amazing women athletes out here
today it makes me so proud
now this is the first year that a trans
woman is in the competition how do you
feel about that
amazing i feel honored to be a part of
history i have a lot of incredible trans
friends who are athletes and so we're
all inspired this woman's competing
uh-huh and uh have you actually ever met
heather swanson
uh no i've never competed against her
before no she's not exactly
your average trans athlete well what is
an average
trans athlete honestly i find that kind
of bigoted david
okay heather swanson is actually joining
us now
miss swanson how does it feel to be
competing today
i can't tell you how free i feel now
that i've started identifying as a woman
now that i can compete as female i'm
ready to smash the other girls
and is it correct you just started
identifying as female two weeks ago
i'm not here to talk about my transition
i'm here to kick some [ __ ] ass
sir it's still funny right it's still
funny but
now it's not satire
now it's reality that is happening
and it's not just at some random
competition in the middle of nowhere
that is happening at the olympics now
that guy maybe without the beard
is this but this giant burly dude
with big muscles is going to be
competing against a woman
and we're all going to have to pretend
that that's totally normal and fine
and good actually and then when he
does very very well at the competition
uh we all have to pretend that that's an
amazing historic thing
sometimes you'll hear from the left that
no there is no
evidence that trans women do any better
or have any unfair advantage against
real women
they wouldn't call them real women
they'd say it's just another variety of
women
that is just fake there was a random
twitter account called
rip x for nutmeg that posted a little
thread on this last night
just and this is just a handful we do
not have time to go through all of the
examples
uh 1998 to 2012
laurel hubbard that guy who's now going
to be at the olympics
failed to qualify for a single
international men's tournament
as a professional weightlifter 2013
hubbard transitions quote unquote at age
35
and from 2014 to 2021 hubbard qualifies
for 11
international women's tournaments
including the olympics i think he got an
advantage
i don't know i'm no expert 2017 cc
telfer is ranked 390th among male
ncaa division 2 athletes in the 400
meter hurdles
in 2018 telfer transitions to pretend to
be a woman
2019 telfer is a national ncaa division
two women's 400 hurdle champion
2021 telfer hopes to qualify for the
olympics 2013 to 2015
hannah mouzy made 22 appearances for the
australian men's
handball team scoring zero goals 2015
mancy transitions in 2018
amid controversy mancy is allowed to
play six times for the
australian women's handball team scoring
23 goals huh
well i think he might think hannah may
have gotten a little advantage there
maybe from
his physique and his biochemistry before
2015 golfer haley davidson won
zero men's tournaments doesn't even look
like he qualified for any tournaments
2015 he transitions 2021 davidson
becomes the first male to win a women's
professional golf tournament 2019 mary
gregory mary
who had transitioned as an adult takes
up just takes it up
professional women's weightlifting and
at his first tournament
won all nine events at the 100
raw weightlifting federation competition
and broke four world records in the
process
just kind of took it up one day but you
know she
transitioned so it's totally totally
kosher you all remember fallon fox
before 2006 fallon fox was in the u.s
navy he's a dude
then he transitioned and then from 2012
to 2014 he becomes an mma fighter he won
all but one of his fights and in one
fight he cracked cracked a woman's skull
open
the list goes on i mean i have so many
more examples of this here do not let
them tell you
that there is no evidence there's never
been an example of a trans woman having
an advantage
over a another woman over a cisgendered
woman it's just not true
they obviously have a built-in advantage
they win or come very close to winning
almost every time under some extremely
extenuating circumstances like
like some some of these guys will take
up the sport way late
but they'll still do better than the
women why because they're bigger and
stronger
hey stop right there i'm glad you liked
the video there's a whole episode go
watch it right now you can watch it on
youtube it's called controlling
words controlling minds you can also
listen at apple podcast google play
spotify stitcher
you can subscribe there leave the
five-star review ring the bell subscribe
here and speaking of controlling words
controlling minds you can order not
pre-order but order my book
was just released today speechless
controlling words controlling lines go
order it
see you next time
[Music]
you